[Musique]
monsieur croyez vous que le péage sur
l'autoroute soit justifiable me suis
jamais posé la question vraiment jamais
n'ont trouvé normal de payer 100 francs
pour faire quelques kilomètres pour une
petite partie non mais pour une grande
partie oui je trouve que c'est normal
pour la conception des attentes
on peut évidemment de vous permettre
d'avoir des routes autant je vais être
obligé d'utiliser une autoroute à péage
et vous la prenez quand même par in
parce que ses parents qui payent autre
aspect du problème celui des commerçants
qui travaillent sur les nationales
maintenant doubler par les autoroutes et
qui de ce fait voient diminuer leur
chiffre d'affaires comme par exemple ce
pompiste ce potier et 7 aubergiste de la
nationale 6 monsieur est ce que
l'ouverture de l'autoroute vous à
enlever des clients effectivement il n'a
enlevé parce que je vois que depuis que
je suis là depuis cet après-midi
d'habitude je faisais une quinzaine de
clients dans l'après-midi facilement
j'en ai fait deux après midi qui m'ont
pris disons pour 3000 francs de super
d'habitude je faisais non mon après-midi
facilement mais 35 mille quarante mille
francs donc vous êtes contre l'autoroute
et bien c'est à dire contre qu'est ce
que vous voulez c'est la circulation
qu'il demande mais enfin personnellement
ça m'enlève beaucoup de clients ça
m'enlève surtout beaucoup de pourboire
parce que comme on fait son service
comme il faut et bien on compte à peu
d'ici à la fin de la journée voyez-vous
il tait absolument à des diables que six
autoroutes continue à progresser comme
le fait actuellement
on perdra au moins 50% de la clientèle
seuls des bons clients qui nous
connaissent depuis dix
sept ans viendront nous voir pour voir
notre belle bourgogne l'autoroute le
matin c'est plus rapide plus rapide on
ne s'arrête plus il n'y a plus la
circulation vivait auparavant se fait
pas l'ombre d'un doute mais simplement à
une bière à roulement à roulement on a
plus de roulement ouvriers le chiffre
d'affaires a baissé à huy or il faut
compter 50 % déjà pour les fêtes enfin
je m'aperçois qu'en fait je me baisse de
50% le matin qu'elle est nous faire
lentement
à quelques kilomètres de là le même
problème s'est posé il y a quatre ans et
la situation semble maintenant plus
optimistes
monsieur vous êtes hôtelier est ce que
la déviation à gêner votre commerce à
gênés oui du fait qu' environ un an
s'est écoulé durant lequel on n'a pas vu
pratiquement de clientèle et on commence
à s'ennuyer
mais petit à petit tout est revenu en
l'ordre et les clients sont revenus plus
régulièrement
pourquoi parce qu'il trouvait
certainement un calme et il trouvait
aussi le cadre avait échangé on avait
amélioré
on avait fait certaines choses qui ont
plu aux clients ils sont venus
régulièrement vous avez fait ces choses
parce que vous n'avez plus clientèle
lorsqu'il y avait moins de clients il a
fallu faire quelque chose pour les
rapides pour les ramener
comment envisagez vous l'avenir bah on
pense maintenant à force de tous les
pays - des vies on pense sur la
clientèle va rechercher quand même les
endroits isolés
de plus en plus quoi allez on voit ça un
peu mieux quoi vous avez bon espoir
je pense oui je pense que dans les
années à venir et pu avec un peu de
publicité on devrait pouvoir s'en sorte
et il est évidemment difficile de
contenter tout le monde
mais de toutes les façons l'autoroute et
la solution de l'avenir
et vous quel et partir en vacances vous
serez très certainement de notre avis
[Musique]